If the creators of "American Pickers" had it
their way, viewers would feel as if everything
about the show is authentic and impromptu. When
it comes to finding and buying interesting items
from collectors across the country, the show
frames it as if everything is spontaneous.
The show's star pickers - or at
least the original star pickers,
Frank and Mike, either spot something
that piques their interest on the road,
or their storefront superstar, Danielle, calls
them with a tip on a potential picking place.
Regardless of the method, Frank and Mike's
picking journey across America looks natural.
Of course, as with all reality shows,
there's a little more orchestration
behind the camera than the show's producers
really want fans to know. Take a touch of
reality away from the reality show, and it
becomes much more entertaining. As such,
you might not be surprised to learn that Frank
and Mike aren't always the ones who do the pickingon "American Pickers."
On top of that, they
might not even handle much of the negotiating.
No matter the TV show, there's always a great
deal of preparation that goes behind every
episode prior to filming, and reality shows are
no exception. Even if a person's behaviors and
reactions are authentic and unscripted, someone
has probably put a ton of effort into making
sure the episode follows a certain guideline.
In the case of "American Pickers," that means
that many locations, collections, and items
are decided long before Frank and Mike even get there.
This is not a huge secret, either.
Part of the process is scouting out areas
and sending public calls to action to find
unique collections and interesting locations.
According to a Go San Angelo article
about a local store featured on the show,
there's a long process that sellers go
through before anyone from "American
Pickers" even goes to the chosen
location to look around. In this case,
the store in question was Ken's Toys. The
owner, Ken Young, explained that he had "a
three-week lead" before the production crew
showed up. Before that, the producers have, "...a 'snoop.'
They get somebody to go into a site
and look around. The man who came in that day,
he gave me his card. Then I got a phone call
and they said when they would be coming."
Young and his family stated that Mike and everyone
involved in the show were
"knowledgeable" and kind,
and they were really interested in the stories
behind the items, which Young was happy to tell.
There's nothing casual about the pickers
process, and there's a lot of earnest
effort put into finding interesting locations
and objects to be featured on the show. But
if you think that the producer's job stops at
finding collections, however, you'd be wrong.
In addition to scouting certain collections and
items, the producers actually do a fair amount
of the negotiations. Not to discredit the picking
skills of Frank and Mike, who truly are the realdeal.
However, producers often negotiate prices
beforehand, according to Living101. That said,
Frank and Mike have been known to continue
haggling after the seller and producers have
agreed on a price. As it's their job, they always
want to ensure that they can get the best profit
margin for the sale, and it's an aspect of the
business that makes the show feel more real.
It makes perfect sense that the production team
would be skilled at finding and negotiating sales.
The responsibility can't be completely on Frank
and Mike, and in reality, if the two men were the
only ones doing any picking, "American Pickers"
would move at a much slower pace than it does.
Regardless, the entire process might be
something to consider next time you see
Mike or Frank "randomly" discover a great item in
a collection they supposedly just stumbled upon.
In other words, the “reality” of this
reality show is a bit pre-planned.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
American Pickers are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.